amazon announced tuesday that founder
jeff bezos will step down from his role
as ceo later this year
in q3 bezos will transition to executive
chair of the amazon board and will
continue to be involved with the company
amazon web services chief executive andy
jassy will transition into the role of
ceo
in a letter to employees the billionaire
said that he plans to focus on his
passions like the day one fund
which fights homelessness and builds
schools and low-income communities
and the bazel's earth fund which funds
climate change initiatives
the announcement came as amazon
announced record profits of 7.2 billion
dollars in the last quarter of 2020.
under jasi amazon web services has taken
the lead in the cloud computing space
they've beaten out google and microsoft
for market share landed big clients such
as zoom
and accounted for 67 of the entire
company's operating profit
last quarter
you